just outside of the US capital a more
peaceful scene was unfolding nearly
300,000 Americans gathered in support of
Israel in support of the Jewish people
and what was a sharp contrast to the
anti-israel protests that have erupted
not only around the country but around
the world by the way we didn't notice
today any flag burning or any vandalism
or hateful graffiti uh spray painted
onto national monuments and there were
no assaults or acts of intimidation no
genocidal chance of from The River To
The Sea no signs calling for a global
violent religious Revolution no instead
demonstrators draped in Israeli and
American flags held pictures of the men
the women the little children kidnapped
and killed by Hamas they prayed for
their safe return in the case of those
taken hostage and for a more peaceful
world free from terrorism and
anti-Semitism take a look are you aaz
amazed at how many people have arrived
here today to show their support and
solidarity for the Israeli government
and to speak out against what happened
on October 7th I I really am it was
really a horrific day for the world you
know what happened on October 7th this
is literally this is the moment this is
once in a lifetime when you know Jews
come together non-jews come together to
clearly declare that we need to be on
the right side of history and this is it
this is right here right now this
country was founded on people escaping
oppression we're just trying to live our
lives we're not marching down the
streets calling for the death of anyone
we just want to live that's all we're
trying to do what is the message that
you hope to get across to the American
people today I have to bring back the
hostages and Hamas started this war
there was a ceasefire October 7th and
they broke it and they countlessly
murdered thousands of Israelis
and it's a time that they uh let the
hostages go so Terror never wins we are
not going to stop fighting it we will
stand up to it we will be here in
Washington and every place else it takes
to let the world know Israel is here to
stay it's not going away and we will
defend her with all of our might now
make no doubt about it this is a David
versus Goliath battle between the
world's only Jewish State and a tiny
strip of land in the Middle East versus
enemies clearly from every direction one
of those enemies Hamas in the South
murdered over 12200 Israelis in a single
day many of these victims raped and
tortured some beheaded many taken
hostage according to reports Hamas
brought children as young as 10 to take
part in that attack on October the 7th
this is a barbaric group of terrorists
and now they are under Gaza City's
largest hospital which by the way this
has been their MO for years meaning they
fire their Rockets from schools and from
hospitals and we also believe a major
battle is UN unfolding at this hour and
according to us officials this is where
Hamas chose to build their main military
command center right under the hospital
again they're using patients they're
using doctors they're using children
nurses all is human Shields now Israel
has offered to transfer patients to
field hospitals and provide mobile
incubators for newborns as prime
minister Netanyahu said on this program
last night but so far it is not clear
that Hamas is allowing anybody to leave
that building they're using those people
hopefully they think to save their lives
in a different hospital nearby Israeli
soldiers Unearthed yet another Hamas
Command Center below ground take a look
complete with weapons and explosives and
they were even grenades in there and
RPGs found in a children's playroom and
by the way also evidence that hostages
including babies were being held
Underground there's no denying that
Hamas is just pure evil in our time now
for most decent people if you have a
conscience if you have a soul uh if you
have a brain that actually works uh on
both sides of the aisle it's simple it's
there's no ambiguity here you should
have moral Clarity but for some reason
the far-left in this country the ones
that cry about microaggression and
misgendering they're now out in full
force excusing the kidnapping the rape
the torture the murder you almost never
hear a bad word uttered about Hamas at
one of their anti-israel Israeli
protests and unfortunately on Capitol
Hill some of these same idiots are
Congressional staffers pay attention to
this they recently staged a walk out why
to protest America's support for the
world's only Jewish State elsewhere in
the Washington swamp more than 500
bureaucrats ac across 40 different
federal agencies signing a letter
rebuking Joe Biden's public support for
Israel privately he's not been as
supportive publicly he's been trying to
say the right things this is what your
radicalized Democratic party is today so
what is wrong with these people and
where were they when Arabs were gassed
by Assad in Syria I don't recall the
protests or maybe during mul's
obliteration during the battle against
Isis or during the ongoing proxy war in
Yemen you know where hundreds of
thousands died why is it that they have
suddenly discovered the word ceas fire
when Israel is involved is it because
they hate the Jews uh many of them
openly say it is it because they want
Israel wiped off the map they're openly
saying that too in the United States the
Biden Administration is reportedly now
giving huge amounts of money to mosques
this is the Biden Administration and
other Islamic centers that have been
preaching or have a history of preaching
hatred against the Jewish people and
against Israel that look at this that
includes
$100,000 to to one California mosque run
by an Imam who prayed that Jews will be
annihilated in a war over the Holy Land
the Biden Administration is also
reportedly now planning to free up to
another get this $10 billion for the
mullers in Iran that is now Frozen in
Iraq Iran is the world's number one
state sponsor of Terror they they they
turned a blind eye to them selling their
oil which resulted in anywhere from 80
to 100 billion
in their coffers to ferment more terror
Iran that help plot plan scheme what
happened on October 7th Iran that's
providing and trading the Weaponry uh of
Terror that is being used against Israel
has the Biden Administration lost their
mind why is since the Obama Biden
Administration and now the Biden
Administration this Obsession to give
billions of dollars to the number one
state sponsor of Terror the mullers of
Iran that chant death to Israel and
death to America remember the last time
that Biden decided to unfreeze billions
of Iranian dollars a few weeks later
well Iran's proxy that's when Hamas
launched one of the worst Terror attacks
in history and now our strongest Ally in
the Middle East is in for a fight for
their survival and literally you know
they're going block by Block House by
house hospital by Hospital against a
terrorist organization whose own Charter
calls for the destruction of Israel the
people that are using women and children
as defensive weapons but less than two
months into this war there they have
already reached the heart of hamas's
military infrastructure and we do
believe that this critical battle is
underway as we speak hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else